hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar genetically engineered custom
cell lines for pre-clinical research and
bio manufacturing this webinar is part
of the fifth annual drug discovery and
development virtual conference and i'm
susie valdez of labrutz and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by
milliporesigma for more information
about our sponsor please go to
www.sigmaaldrich.com
now let's get started before we begin i
want to remind you that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
the help desk button located at the
bottom of the screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr stacy ward an
r d manager in advanced genetic and cell
technologies at millipore sigma for a
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the left top
of your screen dr ward welcome you may
now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction
the life science business of merck kgaa
darmstadt germany operates as milipor
sigma in the us and
canada in today's presentation i will
start with a discussion of cell design
studio who we are and what we do
i will then talk about some gene editing
technologies that we use in our
workflows and some automation
investments we have made to improve
timelines
i will show some examples of project
workflows and finish up with the
advantages of working with us as your
research partner
cell design studio or cds is based in st
louis missouri in the united states
we are a group of scientists with over
13 years of established experience
generating cell models
we are part of the millipore sigma gen m
or gene editing and novel modalities
franchise
and what do we do we generate custom
engineered cell lines for our customers
from initial project scoping to project
updates and final summary we communicate
openly and regularly with you
our workflows are flexible and
customizable to what you need and our
customers always own the edited cells
developed during the project
so what kind what type of cell models
can we make for you
really anything that you could possibly
imagine
so we often modify genes things as small
as single nucleotide polymorphisms with
single base conversion
all the way to gene knockouts by
introducing insertions and deletions
which result in premature stop codons
larger targeted integrations and even
building reporter cell lines
we can deliver you modified pools of
cells as well as single cell clones
as well as engineering most mammalian
cell types including primary cells and
induced pluripotent stem cells
the applications of the cell lines that
we engineer range from disease modeling
to building cellular reporters models
for drug screens target id and
validation and even high content
analysis
and as your research partner we aim to
solve the toughest problems in the
industry by collaborating with the
global scientific community
we really are your research partner not
a cro
we have phd scientists with over a
decade of experience in engineering
cells and over the course of our group
we have engineered over 200 different
genes in over 300 different cell lines
everything from immortalized tumor cell
lines to stem cells to primary immune
cells
and we really do stand behind the
statement that any modification any
target any cell type including the most
challenging cell lines
we perform in an r d centric environment
so you will have direct communication
with the scientists working on your
project we utilize state-of-the-art
technology and methods for clonal
selection and validation
and i will show you some recent
investments in automation that have
significantly shortened our project
timelines
we have engineered dozens of ips cell
lines used for applications including
lineage reporters for cell-based assays
and snip modifications for disease
modeling
this is a slide showing the many tools
that we use to engineer our cell lines
we primarily use crispr and zinc finger
nucleases for all of our targeted
gene editing projects
we also use short hairpin rnas
specifically for those projects in which
modification of
that locus or that gene is predicted to
be lethal or have a significant growth
defect
for projects that do not require
targeted methods we often use lentivirus
or simply plasma delivery
and our research areas range from cell
therapy and gene therapy to immuno
oncology and induced pluripotent stem
cells
we perform in both the research and
discovery space as well as more
downstream applications including
process development analytical
development and manufacturing which i'll
talk about later in the talk
so this is a slide demonstrating some of
the technology and automation
investments that we've made over the
past few years
by investing in these materials and
machines we have significantly shortened
our project timelines as well as
increase the success rate for our
projects
i can start by talking about our dna
synthesizer which we use to synthesize
crispr zfns and donors in-house
we also have multiple nuclear factor
machines which you use to deliver the
materials to any multitude of different
types of cells
within our facility we have multiple
facts orders and facts analyzers here's
a picture of our fox aria that we use
for both pool enrichment as well as
single cell cloning
and for those cell lines that do not
perform well in flow cytometry mediated
cloning
we have also purchased an als cell
selector which is a fully robotic
colony picker that allows us to
image colonies pick them and then array
them into a 96 well plate
when we perform single cell cloning for
our projects it's very important that we
are confident that colonies have
actually um been derived from one single
cell that sat down
we do this by using our clone select
imager for high throughput imaging in
which we can image multi-well plates
rapidly and actually monitor cell growth
with time
and link all of the images together
when it comes to genotype confirmation
for our projects we utilize both digital
droplet pcr as well as next generation
sequencing methods both of which we have
within our group
and finally when um a project calls for
protein phenotyping we can use both our
flow cytometry capabilities for antibody
mediated staining or fluorescent protein
analysis
as well as
things like our in-cell analyzer which
we can use
as a microscopy-based method
all of our projects are divided into
phases and are milestone driven
this slide shows an example workflow for
one of our cds classic or research use
only projects
by dividing our projects into phases
this reduces customer risk and allows
for maximum project flexibility the cds
team will work with you to reassess
technical strategy based on project
progress so if the original workflow is
not working for the cell line or the
locus that we are editing we can rapidly
pivot and try additional strategies
in addition all pricing is associated
with each project phase so you are
billed only for the work that has been
initiated by the cds team
and this is another example in which
this type of workflow enhances our
position as your research partner
the phases begin with a technical
evaluation of the project in which we
will identify any potential pain points
that we anticipate as well as give you a
projected timeline for how the project
will progress
we then move into nucleus design and
assembly of any reagents that we may
need during the course of the project
we deliver these reagents to
a pool of cells and always confirm
activity within that heterogeneous pool
before moving into single cell cloning
once we have identified single cell
clones we will confirm genotype and we
always present all genotypes that we
find within those clones to you and you
as a customer
can decide which clones you want us to
expand and bank for delivery to you
although we can edit any mammalian cell
lines that you send to us we also have a
in agreement with ecac which allows us
to use their cell lines and here is a
table that lists
um
all of the cell lines that we consider
our in-house cell lines so these are
cell lines that we have
that we have
thoroughly tested within our workflow we
know how they grow we know how they
perform
we know how to clone them we know how to
nuclear affect them
so use of any of these cell lines
significantly decreases project timeline
since we don't need to do some of the
upfront work for a cell line that we are
taking in
if you are interested in using any of
these cell lines please reach out to us
and we can discuss your next project
so what are some examples of these
research use only projects that we've
been talking about
they really range from things like
building disease models as well as
control cell lines to screening cell
lines
on the top right of this slide shows an
example of a potential snip project so
this is a lipoprotein
in which sniffs or single nucleotide
base pair changes have been identified
within the literature and clinical
samples as being either disease
associated or disease protective
so what we can do is take in your cell
line we can genotype the parentals so we
know what the genotype that each of
these base pairs is that we're starting
with
and we can propose a project in which we
can convert any of those snips to either
a disease associated or disease
protective snip
and in that way this cell line
remains the same so you can culture them
with the same media the same plastics
roughly the same kinetics as long as
there's no
growth phenotype after editing and it
really does make for a better better
model for your downstream testing
on the bottom right of the slide is an
example of what you can do with the gene
knockout model
so if
you're interested in studying the
potential function of a gene we can use
targeted nucleases to introduce
out-of-frame mutations that result in
premature stop codons we can also do
some phenotyping of the cells to
demonstrate that there is no rna or
protein then being produced
and you can then use these cell lines as
well as either the parental cell or a
mock cell that went through the entire
editing process but does not have
the same gene knockout
and again in this way you can use
matched sets of cells for your studies
which increase reproducibility for your
experiments
so here are some
examples of the data that may be
presented to you during the course of
one of these projects
in this example we were generating a
gene knockout
we first designed the targeted nucleuses
in this example crispr
guides that will target an appropriate
region of one of the coding exons we do
this bioinformatically all as well as
with an eye on any potential off targets
we deliver these rnp's to the parental
cell line thus generating a
nuclear-affected pool
we will genotype this pool using next
generation sequencing methods as shown
in the top middle in which you can see
the insertions and deletions that the
cell introduced to this locus
in this way we can get a numerical
readout of what the efficiency of these
guides were within the cell and we know
approximately how many cells are
potentially knocked out
once we move on to single cell cloning
on the bottom of the slide this is an
image from our clone select imager in
which we are imaging a 96 well plate of
single cell sorted
clones
you can see that there are wells that
contain
cells that were derived from one single
cell that laid down and formed a colony
we can also quickly see that there are
wells that contain two such colonies
which indicated that two cells sat down
and thus this sample is not clonal
on the upper right we will always
confirm clonal genotype using typically
pcr based methods we will run them in
agarose gels as well as doing digital
droplet pcr or next generation
sequencing
and depending on the project we can also
do some phenotyping assays for you we
can do things like elisa-based methods
as well as using our flow cytometer
analyzers to do antibody staining
to determine whether there is protein
being produced
in addition all of this data will be
presented to you as our customer during
regularly scheduled update meetings and
you will have access to all of this data
our services are customized for either
research or commercial use
so our research field of use still
contains the same products and services
that are high quality a flexible r d
partnership
and these are research use licensed
deliverable cell lines that were
engineered with crispr cast 9 zfn or
lente virus
research use only typical typically
falls within the early discovery field
of use and lead optimization
if your project is moving more into
preclinical and clinical development
manufacturing or quality control then
this type of project would fall under
our commercial field of use
this is cell line development with
enhanced documentation requirements
you as the client will approve all of
our raw materials and batch record
documents
and we will work with you with
regulatory expertise to drive success of
your program
both types of these projects are
industry-leading service for all
applications we always use the same
state-of-the-art technology and methods
the same type of direct communication
and a dedicated project management team
if we compare our two offerings of our
research use only or cds classics in our
commercial field of use or cds ultra
both types of projects contain detailed
scoping consultation regular update
meetings and the flexibility to pivot
project scope as needed they also both
contain customizable deliverables to
what you need at the end of the project
milestone-based pricing and always
client ownership of the engineered cell
line
our cds ultra projects also include
dedicated lab space for the project
client documentation approval
full traceability and approval of raw
materials
regulatory expertise for
biomanufacturing
and an option for cgmp cell banking via
our bioreliance service
the project workflow of cds ultra
projects appears very similar to that of
our research use only
some important differences to point out
are that they always begin with a
document approval and material
procurement phase
in this way we can get all of the
materials that we need for your project
and
keep track of things like lot numbers
and expiration dates and you as the
customer will proactively approve all of
our documents before we start
the actual engineering of the cells and
the technologies you use are similar if
not identical to that of our research
use only projects but you'll notice in
blue that every phase has an additional
documentation phase built in
and this is for the enhanced
documentation that is required for
future regulatory body filings
the type of customer that would need one
of these cds ultra projects are ones who
needs engineered cells for more
downstream applications like cell
therapies potency assays quality control
or quality assurance or batch release
for some examples
and is it important to note that this
enhanced documentation cannot be
retroactively added on to any project so
if you start a research use only project
with us and we do not discuss this
enhanced documentation
we can't engineer yourselves and then at
the end of the project kind of
retroactively go back and formulate
these documents it's something that must
be agreed upon before the project begins
here are some examples of cds ultra
projects that we have performed
in the first example our customer was in
the cell therapy space they already had
an established engineering platform
utilizing plasmid transfection they had
a cell type they wanted to use as well
as a phenotyping assay for the
generation of a protein producing cell
line
our initial scoping resulted in
customization of the number of clones
we used customer specific records and
reports based on enhanced documentation
throughout the project
and the project evolved during the
course of engineering which resulted in
further genotyping of the cells
including some whole genome sequencing
that we performed for them and one of
these projects thus far has resulted in
the fda granting an orphan drug
designation for the systel line
a second example of a project is a
customer in the gene therapy space
this customer needed three knockout cell
lines for a potency release assay
extensive initial scoping resulted in
the use of zinc finger nuclease
technology as well as the customization
of the number of clones
in addition we arranged for shipment of
the engineered cells to a third party
for phenotypic testing before the
customer decided which clones they
wanted expanded in banks
and also the customer had specific
records and reports that were based on
enhanced documentation used throughout
the project
so some potential
projects in the future that
might be utilized under the cds ultra
workflow
when we think about the immuno oncology
space quite often a lot of the early
discovery is done using patient samples
and clinical samples
so in this example on the right a
heterogeneous tumor sample from a
patient is used
and can be separated into different cell
types like the tumor cells the stromal
cells and the immune cells
and early discovery can be performed
using single cell analysis or genotyping
and phenotyping on each of these
different cell groups
and this is wonderful for finding
initial hits and trying to determine
different pathways that might be
druggable
or important for your process
but when we think about moving into the
preclinical and clinical therapeutic
space
these cell types are not amenable to the
workflows that you need for instance
human primary samples are notoriously
difficult to grow in culture there is
high variability between different
patient samples they require specialized
media for growth they are quite often
passage limited so if you're thinking
about building an assay for something
like a potency release
based on some of these potential drug
targets you wouldn't really want to use
cells that were derived from patients
and that's where we can help as your
research partner
we can engineer in whatever
modifications of the genome you need to
either build a tumor cell model or even
editing immune cells that you can use in
vitro to test your potential therapeutic
and move it on into more downstream
applications
so some of the advantages of our
enhanced documentation if we think about
the entire upstream and downstream
ecosystem and workflow
starting with cell line development in
the upper left hand side of the screen
all the way down into gmp manufacturing
of either your therapeutic or your
cell line to be used for a release assay
we perform in the upstream space so
upstream cell line development lies
outside of any cgmp requirements
however all of the downstream
manufacturing of these materials
requires the use of gmp
and it's important to remember that with
the changing regulatory landscape
we need to consider any future
requirements for filings so if you are
in this space and interested in pursuing
an engineering project with us
that could move into downstream
applications
i would encourage you to think about our
cds ultra offering
in addition to our custom cell lines
that we engineer for our customers we
also have a number of specialized cell
lines that are available for immediate
purchase off of our website
these include our mono allelic hla lines
in which we have knocked out expression
of all class 1 mhcs
and then individually reintroduced one
class 1 hla at a time
in addition we have our tumor-associated
antigen expressing cell lines these are
cell lines that were knocked out for
expression of potential tumor-associated
antigen and we've phenotypically
confirmed that they are knocked out for
expression of the protein
and we were then able to introduce
either low expression levels or high
expression levels of the
tumor-associated antigen thus building a
panel that you can use to test your
therapeutics
if you are interested in doing some
engineering of cell lines on your own
but don't want to use crisprs or vfns
we offer our fluxed landing pad cell
lines a schematic of this is shown on
the bottom of the slide
we have knocked in an ef-1 alpha
promoter driving expression of a red
fluorescent protein into a safe harbor
locus of a number of different human
cell lines
both the promoter and the rfp are
flanked by unique lock sites and in this
way you can purchase these cell lines
and use cream recombinase technology to
then exchange either the promoter or the
red fluorescent protein or the entire
cassette with whatever
sort of donor molecule you need for your
purposes
and if you are interested in more
microscopy based assays
we offer a number of different triple
tagged cell lines in the example on this
slide we have tagged tubulin beta actin
and laminin with different fluorescent
proteins
and in this way you can use high content
microscopy to monitor any morphological
changes within these cells
so to finish up cell design studio is
part of the process that allows
us as a company to offer you end-to-end
cell therapy
workflows from research to manufacturing
so we perform in the cell engineering
and cell characterization parts of the
workflow but our company also offers a
number of different production tools and
raw materials that meet gmp standards as
well as offering process development
assistance
and this allows us to offer you seamless
integration of services including custom
cell models assays
viral vector cgmp production cell and
virus banking as well as biosafety
testing
thank you so much for your attention
dr ward i want to thank you again for
your time today and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
kaijan for sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during our
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until february 2024
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone bye